beirut iragna cucina ma soprattutto una
nuova puntata di una youtuber in cucina
o ci prepareremo una torta buonissima e
io adoro ma che ad ora soprattutto salvo
infatti per il suo compleanno ti ho
fatto la sorpresa io ho preparato la
torta preferita era la prima volta che
la facevo è venuta buonissima e quindi
mi avete visto nelle delle storie mentre
preparavo e le foto eccetera eccetera mi
aveva chiesto di farvi vedere come si
prepara la new york ci spiega il frutto
di bosco quella che preparano oggi
insieme a voi ea cheesecake proprio
originale quella cotta nel forno ed è
veramente squisita quindi e ci sono
tante ricette in giro ma questa è la mia
preferita ma abbiamo subito con gli
ingredienti che ci servono per la nostra
cheesecake allora per la base che ha
bisogno di 200 g di biscotti secchi
io vi consiglio di lei gesti che sono
perfetti per questa tipologia di torta
100 g di burro pensa che remo invece 600
grammi di philadelphia 150 g di yogurt
nel concetto 20 grammi di zucchero 3
uova una bustina di vanillina e il succo
e la buccia di mezzo limone non trattato
mi raccomando per la decorazione invece
ci servono 200 grammi frutti di bosco 2
cucchiai di zucchero
e un paio di succo di limone iniziamo
preparando alla base quindi metto il 100
g di burro a sciogliere in un pentolino
dopo di che dobbiamo frantumare i nostri
biscotti per comodità io li metto e
storicamente dentro un sacchettino
questo
[Musica]
milito con un mattarello e di franco per
benino perché devono essere appunto
sbriciolati siamo qua dentro
ma iniziamo con le mani abbiamo qualche
niente diverte poi quando solo un
pochino più sbriciolati allora iniziò a
passare mio mazzarello vedete è
automaticamente si sbriciolano una
volontà frantumati i nostri biscotti e
dobbiamo procurarci una tortiera di 20
centimetri possibilmente potete anche
usarne una un po più grossa però
sappiate che agisca in poi non berrà
dell'altra ma verrebbe sottile io credo
ha chiuso questa forma di cuore che
soprattutto e ricordatevi di prendere un
foglio di carta da forno a posizionarlo
sulla base telefono fatto quindi
pensiamo ai nostri biscotti frantumati
in una ciotola
prendiamo il nostro il burro che avevo
fatto sciogliere per over siamo sopra e
poi mescolare chiaramente tutto e andare
a creare la nostra voglia mescoliamo
bene dopo aver mescolato bene versiamo
il tutto dentro la nostra tortiera che
mi raccomando non l'ho detto prima ma
deve essere apribile e soprattutto
dobbiamo premere bene per creare appunto
alla base quindi perché non ci siano
dislivelli cerchiamo di con un cucchiaio
governo ci aiutiamo e la combattiamo
bene
[Musica]
i suoi problemi ecco qua la teniamo in
frigo la mettiamo in frigo e apriamo per
15 minuti
non male se si raffreddi passiamo subito
alla crema
vi ricordo che la ricetta originale
americana prevede l'uso della panna
acida che però in italia è abbastanza
difficile da trovare e quindi
il sostituto come accaduto è lo yogurt
greco che si trova comunque cominciamo
versando appunto la crema spalmabile la
fiat etica mi raccomando 600 grammi n'è
uno in più né uno in meno
una volta versato il formaggio
spalmabile aggiungiamo anche i 120 g di
zucchero e mescoliamo bene facciamo
amalgamare il tutto dopo aver mescolato
crema spalmabile zucchero procediamo con
la scorza del mezzo limone
mi raccomando attenzione alle unghie
perché se vi grattate anche il gel
potrebbe essere un problema
e dopo aver grattugiato il vostro limone
faccio un jazz anche il succo sempre di
questo mezzo rigore
passiamo ad aggiungere lo yogurt greco
che ricordo ne quindi sostituito alla
panna acida che ha messo in america
aggiungiamo le 3 uova 1 2
e ultimo ingrediente per la nostra crema
è la bustina di vanillina sì ad aprirla
perfetto adesso prendiamo un bello
sbattitore elettrico perché tutta la
forza dice non ce l'ho e mescoliamo il
tutto schiette però di 123 a gianfranco
cifra che dopo tornò morire
è questa e non fuori onda
ho tirato fuori dal figlio la nostra
base scusate un bel casino ma come avete
visto a schizza dopotutto è arrivato il
momento di versare la nostra crema che
pesa un sacco e la versiamo la nostra
base
[Musica]
l'età un sacco mamma mia le vere tris
cake americane
[Musica]
una volta ottenuto questo fantastico
risultato andiamo a infornare la nostra
cheese cake and nel forno a 180 gradi e
la facciamo con 150 minuti ci siamo è
arrivato il momento di togliere dal
forno la nostra fantastica cheese cake
attenzione quando sollevate perché
rimane molto morbida quindi è facile
insomma che si apra azioni questo è
l'aspetto che deve avere la vostra
cheesecake una volta volta dal forno e
come potete vedere bella dorata nel
contorno e invece giallo canarino nel
mezzo ma mentre la facciamo a
raffreddare un attimo ho messo i 200 g
di frutti di bosco 2 cucchiai di
zucchero e del succo di limone a cuocere
in un pentolino creeremo così la
copertura il topping di questa
cheesecake che è il passaggio finale per
poi proseguire all'assaggio che la parte
che mi piace di più
una volta tolti dal fuoco e nostri
frutti di bosco che hanno insomma creato
questa salsina un pò liquida e con
alcuni pezzi insomma interi l'andiamo a
versare sopra la nostra
perfetto allora la lasciamo raffreddare
un pochino fuori dopodichè la metterei
in frigo per un'oretta perché penso che
la cheesecake sia meglio gustarla fredda
in questo modo possiamo anche far sì che
la salsina il topping della nostra
cheese cake si solidifichi un attimo e
quindi sia perfetta la nostra cheesecake
la nostra new york cheese cake
[Musica]